♪
>>> MASSIVE EVACUATIONS ARE ;
a
HAPPENING THIS HOUR IN SOUTHERN
UKRAINE
AN IMPORTANT DAM ON THE DNIPRO ;
a
.
QUOTE, CREATE OBSTACLES FOR ANY;
a
UKRAINIAN COUNTEROFFENSIVE.
RUSSIA IS BLAMING UKRAINE.;
a
THROUGH THE DESTROYED PORTION O;
THE DAM YOU CAN SEE THERE.
I WANT TO SHOW YOU ANOTHER ANGL;
a
THAT WE HAVE PULLED IN.
YOU CAN ALSO SEE WHAT LOOKS LIK;
a
.
SOME OF THE DAM'S FACILITIES ;
a
THERE IN THE BACKGROUND, SOME ;
HEAVILY DAMAGED AS THIS FLOOD
UNFOLDED.
>>> WHOA.
WHOA.
WHOA
>> SO FLOODING IS NOW HITTING ;
a
DOWNRIVER IN KHERSON.
MORE THAN 800 PEOPLE HAVE BEEN ;
a
.
ONE UKRAINIAN OFFICIAL SAID ;
a
16,000 PEOPLE ON THE WEST BANK ;
OF THE RIVER ARE NOW IN A ;
a
FOR THEIR PART RUSSIAN OFFICIALS
ARE DOWN PLAYING THE IMPACT OF
ALL OF THIS SAYING THAT THERE I;
a
NO THREAT.
LET'S GET THE LATEST FROM THE ;
a
KHARKIV, UKRAINE, FOR US.;
>> Reporter: WELL, KATE, I CAN ;
a
TELL YOU THAT WE'VE BEEN IN ;
THERE MANNING ARTILLERY
POSITIONS, TANK POSITIONS, ;
a
.
FLOODED OUT, THEIR TRENCHES ;
a
OVERWHELMED.
THEY SAW RUSSIANS ABANDONING
MILITARY LOCATIONS AND IT WAS ;
a
CLEAR TO THEM AT LEAST THAT THE;
RUSSIANS HAD NO IDEA THAT THIS ;
a
NOW, WE DON'T HAVE INDEPENDENT
VERIFICATION OF THIS, BECAUSE
THERE IS VERY, VERY DIFFICULT ;
a
SOURCES THAT CNN HAS WORKED WIT;
IN THE PAST.
IF THAT IS CONFIRMED I SEE NO
REASON AT ALL TO DISBELIEVE IT,;
a
.
TO THE IDEA THAT THIS IS ;
a
ACTUALLY WORSE FOR THE RUSSIANS;
THAN IT IS FOR THE UKRAINIANS.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN ULTIMATELY,
THOUGH, THAT THE RUSSIANS WERE ;
a
NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT ;
HAPPENED AT THE DAM BECAUSE THE;
a
DAM HAD BEEN UNDER RUSSIAN
POSSESSION, IT HAD BEEN IN ;
a
EXTREME DANGER AS A CONSEQUENCE;
SUFFICIENT AMOUNT OF WATER
THROUGH THAT DAM BEFORE.;
a
IT HAD BEEN SHOWING SIGNS THAT ;
IT MIGHT BREACH IN THE LAST DAY
SINCE MAY 28th WITH SIGNS OF
BREACHING WITH WATER GOING OVER;
a
NOW IT HAS BEEN ENTIRELY
BREACHED WITH THIS DISASTROUS ;
a
.
?
>> YEAH, A LOT OF QUESTIONS
STILL AS YOU'RE OFFERING VERY
IMPORTANT CONTEXT AROUND ALL OF;
a
THIS OF WHAT IS BEHIND WHAT ;
CAUSED -- IF THERE IS SOMEONE TO
BLAME FOR WHAT WE'RE SEEING ;
a
.
IT'S VERY MUCH DEVELOPING RIGHT;
a
NOW AS WE SPEAK.
THANK YOU, SAM.
SARA?
>> THE SIGNIFICANCE OF THE DAM
IN SOUTHERN UKRAINE CANNOT BE ;
a
OVERSTATED.
IT BRIDGES THE DNIPRO RIVER ;
a
HOLDING BACK A HUGE RESERVOIR O;
WATER, THE VOLUME NEARLY EQUAL
TO THE GREAT SALT LAKE.
THE DAM STANDS NEARLY 100 FEET ;
a
TALL AND IS ABOUT TWO MILES
LONG.
THERE ARE MULTIPLE TOWNS AND
CITIES, AS YOU JUST HEARD,
DOWNSTREAM, INCLUDING KHERSON.
WATER FROM THE RESERVOIR
SUPPLIES THE CRIMEAN PENINSULA ;
a
EUROPE'S LARGEST.
THE DAM IS ALSO PART OF A NEARB;
a
HYDRO ELECTRIC POWER PLANT.;
UKRAINE'S ENERGY OPERATOR SAYS
IT, TOO, HAS BEEN TOTALLY
DESTROYED.
THIS COULD MAKE UKRAINE'S ENERGY
PROBLEMS EVEN WORSE THAN THEY ;
a
ALREADY ARE.
RUSSIAN FORCES HAVE CONSISTENTLY
TARGETED UKRAINE'S ELECTRICAL ;
a
GRID SINCE THE START OF THEIR
UNPROVOKED INVASION.
>>> LET'S TALK ABOUT THE ;
a
MILITARY SIGNIFICANCE OF THIS
REGION.
PEOPLE KNOW THE AREA WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT SOUTHERN UKRAINE,
I CAN PUSH IN NOW SPECIFICALLY
ON THE RIVER, YOU CAN SEE THE ;
a
RIVER FLOWING RIGHT HERE.;
THIS IS THE DAM AND THIS IS
KHERSON
THAT CITY IN THE SOUTH NOW
CONTROLLED BY UKRAINE, FOR ;
a
UPRIVER FROM THE DAM WHICH IS ;
MAJOR CONCERN RIGHT NOW.
BUT WHEN YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT ;
a
THE MILITARY SIGNIFICANCE OF
THIS MUCH MORE, YOU CAN SEE THA;
a
THE DNIPRO RIVER IS LITERALLY ;
THE DIVIDING LINE BETWEEN ;
a
UKRAINIAN-HELD TERRITORY AND TH;
RUSSIAN OCCUPIED TERRITORY IN ;
a
THE SOUTH.
THE RUSSIANS HAVE BEEN IN CRIME;
a
FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND HAVE ;
.
a
CORNELL CEDRIC LEIGHTON.;
TERRITORY, THIS IS WHERE UKRAIN;
a
HOW DOES THIS DAM BEING
DESTROYED, THIS REGION BEING
FLOODED IN PARTICULAR, HOW DOES;
a
THAT AFFECT THE COUNTEROFFENSIV;
THAT WE ALL EXPECT TO BE COMING
OR MAYBE HAVE ALREADY STARTED
FROM UKRAINE?
>> JOHN, THAT'S GOING TO BE A
HUGE ISSUE FOR BOTH SIDES,
ACTUALLY, AND AS YOU HEARD IN ;
a
SAM'S REPORTING, THERE IS AN
IMPACT ON THE RUSSIAN SIDE AS
WELL.
BUT FOR THE UKRAINIANS THIS IS ;
a
PROBABLY COUNTED ON BEING ABLE ;
TO GO ACROSS THE DNIPRO RIVER
USING AMPHIBIOUS VEHICLES SO
THAT HE COULD GO INTO THE
RUSSIAN-OCCUPIED AREAS OF
SOUTHERN UKRAINE.
THIS MAKES IT MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO DO, NOT IMPOSSIBLE;
a
WATER THAT'S COMING THROUGH THI;
AREA AND ALSO THE IMPACT THAT I;
a
SUCH AS BRIDGES, ROADS, YOU
KNOW, AND THE THINGS THAT YOU
WOULD ENCOUNTER IN A NORMAL
MILITARY OPERATION.
>> THIS WAS, BY THE WAY, ONE OF
THE MAJOR BRIDGES FROM THE ;
a
UKRAINIAN-HELD TERRITORY INTO
THE RUSSIAN-HELD TERRITORY, THAT
BRIDGE IS NOW VERY MUCH GONE AN;
a
.
YOU TALKED ABOUT WHAT THIS MEAN;
a
FOR THE RUSSIANS, CEDRIC, I JUST
WANT TO POINT OUT THIS IS CRIMEA
WHERE THE RUSSIANS HAVE OCCUPIE;
a
THERE WAS A CANAL ALSO THAT ;
CONNECTS THAT DAM AREA WITH ;
a
.
?
>> SO AS FAR AS THE RUSSIANS AR;
a
CONCERNED, YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT,
JOHN N POINTING OUT THAT THE
CANAL THAT SUPPLIES WATER TO
CRIMEA IS A CRITICAL SOURCE FOR
THEM.
ONCE THAT SUPPLY IS CUT, THAT ;
a
REALLY MAKES IT HARD FOR THEM TO
SUSTAIN THE CIVILIAN POPULATION;
a
.
IT ALSO MEANS THAT THE MILITARY;
a
AS WELL FOR THE RUSSIANS.;
COURSE HAS TO BE CONSIDERED IS
THE IMPACT ON THE RUSSIAN FORCE;
a
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY TOUGH
BECAUSE APPARENTLY THEY DID NOT
KNOW THAT THIS WAS GOING TO ;
a
R
UKRAINIAN EFFORTS TO GO ACROSS
THIS PARTICULAR AREA OF UKRAINE;
a
RUSSELL WESTBROOK IT IS ON THE
DNIPRO RIVER.
THE AREA WHERE I THINK SOME
PEOPLE HAD BEEN EXPECTING THE ;
a
THROUGH TO THE SEA OF AZOV AND
CUT OFF CRIMEA AND THE LAND ;
a
BRIDGE HERE.
HOW DOES THE DESTRUCTION OF THE;
a
DAM PERHAPS IMPACT THAT?;
UKRAINIAN SIDE RIGHT NOW?;
a
RUSSIAN TROOPS WOULD MOVE ;
WOULD HAPPEN TO THE UKRAINIAN ;
a
TROOPS.
I THINK SEVERAL THINGS WERE ;
a
EXACTLY WHERE YOU MENTIONED THA;
THEY WOULD HAVE CROSSED INTO
THAT PART OF THE SOUTHERN AREAS;
a
AZOV.
THEIR MAIN GOAL IS TO CUT THAT ;
a
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT THE;
THAT'S PART OF THE AREA THAT ;